- We asked the Buzzfeed community
to send us their secret menu items,
and we're gonna eat 'em.
- Yeah.
- Hopefully they're good.
I'm from New York, so I've
only had it a couple times.
- Probably like three times a month.
- I'd go probably once a month,
and I go protein style, and I go hard.
- Never tried the secret menu before.
- Also, it's a secret, so,
like, how would I know?
- Ooh.
(laughter)
- This is (censored)!
- I'm holding it.
Okay, there it goes.
- There's nothing to hate about this.
This is like a grilled cheese sandwich,
but with meat.
- If somebody brought me
this and I had to pay for it,
I'd be (censored) irate right now.
- It needs some sauce or something.
- It needs something.
- And, or lettuce, tomatoes, and a bun.
- This is like the inside of your mouth
when you're eating In and Out.
- This is the inside of your stomach.
- My stomach just growled in happiness.
- It's good.
- A stoner walked up to
the cashier at In and Out,
and he was like, "I want
a patty on my fries."
And the guy was like,
"Don't you just want a burger and fries?"
He's like, "No, no, no, no, on it."
- This is just a (censored) patty.
- The ultimate In and Out hack right here.
- It's good.
It adds a little bit of flavor.
- It's so salty.
- It's like, I might as
well grab the Pacific Ocean
and throw it onto this plate.
- This just makes me
really sad for America.
- Oh my God, no!
- God!
- Holy (censored)!
- Oh my God, this is incredible.
- I'm gonna have to have jaw surgery
after taking one bite.
- I don't have the mouth space for this.
- Kinda daunting.
- Okay, you ready?
- I have to practice, hold on.
- I can't!
- It's just too much.
- I, no.
- If I ate this in the morning,
I wouldn't have to eat until the next day.
- This restores my faith in America.
- This is the next
president of our country.
- It's delicious.
- This is the best one so far today.
- Oh my God.
- I love it.
- Yeah, a ton of flavor, it's like, moist.
I know a lot of people hate that word,
but I like that word.
- That kinda looks healthy.
Squeeze.
- I would almost go vegetarian for this.
- You gotta try it.
And I'm sorry about my bad manners, mom.
- It's fantastic.
You're just gonna drink
the whole thing, huh?
Okay.
- She doesn't know what
she's talking about.
- Amazing.
I'm also done, but amazing.
- Wow.
- The ice cream's a little melted.
Oh, it's perfect.
- You have any more of these?
- Today I found $100, and
I got a root beer float.
- Yeah, he found $100.
- Yeah.